geschlagen glaube ich gar nicht mal so
viel was gestorben
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy immer noch
zusammen mit spark of phoenix halle
ruhig man also noch eine weitere dann
mal gucken sollte ganz entspannt ja
jetzt seien willkommen auch ein bisschen
voran hoffentlich ja auf jeden fall
ich muss man endlich meine doofen einen
doofen starb da jetzt einsetzen ich habe
jetzt in der letzten folge falls ihr die
irgendwie nicht gesehen haben solltet
habe ich so einen supertollen staat
bekommen und mit diesem super tollen
starb den des backofens natürlich schon
lange hat kann ich jetzt supertolle mini
uns erschaffen und ich würde sagen ich
mach das jetzt mal einfach ne also das
was ich essen ja habe ich
wo bist du denn gern mal kurz was ich
komme nicht kommen zu dir zu deinem haus
kommt zu 30 findet einfach oder zum
kreise ich finde einfach effektiv hier
nichts zu fressen die ganze zeit schon
ein getreidefeld es waren also möglich
ist schon da danke ganz kurze prozesse
gebratenes steak sagt also seriösen
eingegeben kein ding soll ich mein
masters darf solche familien ist das
egal wo ich die sport- oder sollte ich
bei mir im haus bauen weil die irgendwie
nur wenig hinterher noch eigentlich
geboren wo du willst aber lasst ihn nur
dabei auch die landschaft zerstören ist
weil die reisen alles wieder nach unten
wurde
also das ist nicht so wie mega park mit
dieser meinung turtle wo ich einstellen
kann was diese wie du kannst den grob
sagen was wir machen sollen
okay ich mache das jetzt einfach bei
irgendwem beim haus wenn ich das scheiße
finde ich mach das jetzt hier
so kam ich am besten wissen nicht mal
käme die stellen
neben musst du musst deine taste drücken
der taste ja okay und dann den sagen
hoffentlich christoph einem gast und
dann die gemeinschaft und dann kriegst
du wenn du mit der maus auf boden zeigt
sind starb veranlasst zum chromes
template angezeigt wo das in etwa dann
sein wird
und da muss einfach beide posten
gleichzeitig drücken die autobahn weißt
du was witzig ist ich bin gerne
fledermäuse ich habe diesen medien
gemacht und ich bin kleiner alt sind
und ich kann ihm befehle erteilt das
wird ein klein wenig arbeit machen
ich hab zwei du kannst doch hier machen
wir also vier smax habe ich vier ja ich
habe ja das premium cook pop shop so und
jetzt drücke ich und jetzt mache ich die
gemeinschaft oder soll ich nur dick
machen dick mannschaft ist am besten
weil nur dick heißt dann glaube ich
wieder was anderes detail penis oder
kannst dann manuell festlegen welche art
sie liegen sollen
okay sie machen gration rote nacht das
darf ich jetzt auswählen
ja klar du darfst auswählen wo okay okay
die durch wenn die ganze zeit bekommt
ihr nach rostock debattieren
ihr macht das super und hat irgendwie
befreite feste strukturen machen dass er
mal richtig stark für mich so mächtig
klar du kannst dir übrigens auch
schlagen dann arbeiten die schnelle ich
kann dich schlagen aber infonline ich
möchte ich aber nicht schlagen
dann sollen sie lieber bisschen
langsamer machen aber ich möchte nicht
schlag einschlagen sind ja ich gebe das
hat der modder extra gemacht mich
schnell arbeiten aber ich möchte ihn
nicht schlagen ich habe jetzt nicht
schlagen immer nur einen denen ich das
ist bob wird immer geschlagen weil er
der schwänzt auch immer die arbeit der
sagt dann aber erst krank ab soll
schneller machen
er lag an die ganze sache einfach in
ihren rucksäcken müssten sie ja du
kannst dann auf eine kiste klicken von
etwas weitere entfernungen da kann ich
es als eine kiste ein
aber die sind nicht irgendwann voll mit
ihren rucksäcken oder doch klopp schon
die haben auch begrenzt das inventar
aber dann brauchen die nicht einfach
weiter ab und das fällt dann einfach
daneben ende dann bleiben die dumm
dastehen
ja okay gut das wäre ja noch pech hast
laufen lernt zu dir pupsen alles zu der
außen rennen gleich weiter an bauern
weiter und es ist glaub ich deswegen
software easy access care skaliert ja
bald einfach
als abgebaut von cash das war so witzig
erwarte ich mach jetzt hier ein freund
minions der enter marca group player des
komplett ab
wie kann ja nicht die farbe für alles
okay ich weiß was ist das denn
foxtrott es macht einfach mal ich habe
mich dann fort was ist denn so eine
farbe für foxtrott keine ahnung grün
oder so was ich weiß
ok grün weil wir auch so eine wildnis
leben ist das denn nochmal fünf körper
leben alle in der wildnis ich eigentlich
jetzt tief hinein werden die wälder soll
dann mache ich meine farbe von meinem
haus mache ich mein hut habe ich das ich
mache ist pink pink ok und finster
bisschen schade dass die wii points kann
man das einstellen dass die auch so
angezeigt werden wenn ich da so hin
fliege ich glaube schon wenn du kannst
sie markieren du kannst auf der karte im
raid punkt setzen und dann oder denn die
auf der kleinen wird bei den nicht
angezeigt kommt auf den kleinen wird
werden die angezeigt aber ich möchte
dass die im großen fenster das die
sowieso ein aushängeschild sind quasi
als leider nicht schon aus bei den map
motto was ich machen die wir nie sagen
option
im auto saß heiß an change that may
cause 3
obwohl static vielleicht
es ist nicht das ist ja helme oder güte
kannst du mal hart ruhig mehr katzen
komischen hut aufsetzen wenn du schon
viel geld das was im komischen mut hatte
das kann ich dann rücken random hätte
alles auswählen klar ich bleibe eine
fledermaus fledermaus ohne hut aber sehr
coole ich dann so ein monokel hätte ja
endlich entweder ersten christen in
fetten haufen erstmal aber ich habe
keine spitzhacke mit cool ich will mal
wieder nach hause eigentlich könnte ich
auch immer das direkt vor meinem zuhause
machen an die oberste dings einfach oder
drache bewegt sich und einfach dieses
oberste immer zu bauen mit erde
theoretisch kommen immer diese komischen
zombie fans
ich habe mich jetzt wieder zurücknehmen
nicht hier links parkhilfe claimed ins
barkey genauigkeit aus diesem holz gar
nichts bauen
aus welchem holz aus palm- place kannst
du keinen keine kisten und crafting
table und so machen
klassisch wahrscheinlich weil das von
dem job kraft mottos was ja nicht
vorgang funktioniert
die sn tun mit stone die beiden bücher
und kann endlich mal die landschaft
ziehen
weißt du ob man sich zu generatoren
machen kann wie im mega projekt ahlmann
das will kraft ist nicht mehr drin
das heißt zwar weil dann können unsere
ganze erzählt oppelt logistik system
schafft gehört es geht auch so irgendwie
dass man reisen verdoppeln kann aber ich
habe nicht verstanden wie
gut habe ich ruhe informiert ich habe
jetzt hier mir erwähnt die latics
angeschaut ich habe den mädels chips
mord angeschaut ich hab den minions ort
angeschaut ich hab den hamster und
angeschaut und mir das alles auch an
elsen wundern sich zum moscheenbau mache
ich alles das ist hier sowieso habe ich
zwei kräftig und wie sehen diese
unterschiedlich aus der eine ist
unterdessen zwei verschiedene die haben
verschiedenes design oder einfach im spa
weil du die in zwei verschiedenen
holzsorten gemacht hat das habe ich mir
auch gerade gedacht wenn ich andere
wegschmeißen sonntag nacht ganz zu
schlafen
gerade nicht oder hab ich wollte da sein
darüber kommen ich meine mich stark und
dodi was ist wenn ich musste in essen
stärker das ist von nick romans hier in
den item ich weiß nicht ich glaube du
bist ja durch vergiftete zombie
vielleicht das gegenteil was ich dachte
genau was man kurz ich habe hier
ich kann man mitmachen hatte holz 123
dann wolle darüber geklatscht und ich
habe ein bett kommt endlich mal ein ja
ich bin im mordfall super dass ich das
omni merkel ohne das versteht so
kontakter sich in lediglich hin
lediglich es ist wunderschön wir gehen
heute früh schlafen die sonne geht unter
dann sind wir gefordert ausgeschlafen
und sie am nächsten tag total produktiv
und ich glaube ich suche meine wüste
schon wieder ja viel spaß es wird müssen
dass solche fragen kann man sich so
coole rüstungen machen
ich weiß dass wir bei hexe hatten wir da
konnten uns so sachen machen wie der
fifa moore und die konnte hatte dann
nicht nur eine volle nicht nur voller
rüstung sondern auch dass man damit dann
irgendwie besonders hoch springen konnte
oder man konnte dann besser schlagen
oder weiß ist gar nicht so genau also
von dem es gibt wahnsinnig viele wussten
noch items nicht probier mal im
singleplayer dann vielleicht mal ganz
kurz minuten zu gucken was da gibt oder
einfach mal einmal so reingeht einfach
nur am ort eingeben
dann kriegst du jede menge zeug
vorgeschlagen
ob ich na ja gar nicht was gestorben ich
bin ein fan todesmutig runter geschworen
die war nicht in wolf und ich hatte ein
herz ich habe den tod so ins auge
geguckt er dann hätten wir keine dritte
folge mehr aufnehmen können ich habe
schon gedacht wort paar kratzer moment
darauf durch die erst mal gleich im
fleisch aus oder irgendwie drinks es
gibt auch drinks snacks gibt sogar
nutella brote bachmann bereich wieder am
limit
glaub ich gehe ja nicht gerade froh ach
was ich glaub ich hab keine müsste
gefunden das ist ebenso wie die kakteen
wäre es schnee sich ist nicht weiß ist
wenn du eine wüste findet im soviel
kakteen mit wie es geht und bau die an
weil die braucht man für waffen
obwohl man braucht eigentlich nur eine
web ins bockshorn jagen das relativ
sondern sonne ak-47 ist so geil endlich
wird die so gern haben
ob man so ich schaute mir noch
irgendwelche sachen sind ich mitnehme
jetzt so viel eisen und alles das ist
unglaublich baumann alles gar nicht
jetzt auch einfach mal mit vielleicht
kann man ja trading oder so fossil ja
gibt es auch okay das ist auch im
schrank
ich würde auf einmal angehen alter ich
würde auf einmal angesprungen ich habe
dieses fossil abgebaut und ich dachte da
kommt so ein fossil raus
neben hausmülls es kam etwas weiß was
meine minions und haben wir meinen
ganzen items ins gesicht gesprüht keine
kiste markt hat und ich stehe da nur und
fällt mir sofort und greift die an und
ach dieser in halo master danach war ich
bin ich fertig ich habe profil soll ich
weiß unnötigen sachen wecke die ich
nicht brauche
das habt ihr mir dennoch gegeben die
kleinen süßen soll da oben wo ist der
rest von der rasselbande darf noch ich
hallo
okay das heißt sie setzen quasi einfach
eine kiste hin und dann fokussiere ich
dir auf die m ich frag mich grad kind
die irgendwie aus dieser höhle wieder
raus oder laufen ja vor über ihre taille
nachlaufen
ich hoffe mal dass sie mir nachdem du
kannst befehlen dass sie eine gewisse
stelle gehen sollen aber du kannst du
bei vielen dass ihr folgen sollen zum
beispiel den staat rausholen müssen hier
auch hierher kommen gleich mal aufs
kurze eck ist kein holz so und dann kann
ich die theoretisch einfach könnte jetzt
irgendwo hinfliegen könnt ihr da sagen
okay macht ihr mal meint da mal
irgendwas zusammen
genau dann kannst du halt wieder eine
kiste kann ich die kiste auch einfach
oben hinsetzen oder muss ich die noch
unten die grünen setzen kannst ja oben
setzten darauf auch gerne wieder hoch
das ist doch eines klar wir machen alles
für dich okay stark fühle mich echt zu
mächtig ins kleine fledermaus folgenden
namen fledermaus master schreibt für
eine kommentare wenn ich ging es dann
nahmen so dass sich die böse fehler
motto alle bösen menschen haben
irgendwelche coolen namen aber auch so
einen namen so warte wo habt ihr euch
als erstes rein hierhin hierhin einfach
wunderschöner platz
sollte sich eine kiste hin zur masters
darf an dem ich mach das darf die
gemeinschaft zu denen teleportiert und
kann jetzt sehen wie die da hinlaufen
süß so kommt man hoch jungs
kommt ihr hier hin so ich mach mal was
lustiges war eine kiste ihm hinterher
läuft alles auffrisst was ich liegen
lasse eine laufwerk ist wieso ist hier
nur eine andere sind noch unterwegs
glaube ich ein bass linien frage
vielleicht ist auch meiner
ich weiß nicht mal eine auf den weg
geschickt ablesen endlich nach schön die
pflicht das müsste an deiner sein du
kannst du irgendwie alle sammeln und
wenn halten herumsteht anschnitten als
warum kann die anderen wollen einfach
nicht kommen oder sich noch unterwegs
ich gucke die ganze zeit in den wald
rein ob die irgendwie bekommen
die sind also ich hab jetzt christi der
laufen die ganze hinterher und sammelt
alle items einzig hier verlieren
schiestl auf eine laufende kiste hier
macht das ist auch ein rezept das heißt
luggage und die tele produzieren daher
sammelt alles ein was du liegenlässt
frist einfach alles auf wenn du die
kannst auch wieder ins emmental zurück
dem sommerkino andruck sack was cool ist
wie läuft im hintergrund macht alles weg
die jugend lässt es ist so geil
rumäniens machen gerade wieder die
arbeit irgendwie sind jedoch auf einmal
alle da sind schon irgendwie crazy so
gut und jetzt nämlich einfach den
masters davon clique aus etwas weiterer
entfernung auf die küste ok haben das
mal als jahr nehmen wir nehmen wir als
kiste so und jetzt
damit holte er hat eigentlich eine eine
wüste suchen aber wir sind schon wieder
bei 15 minuten man gleich ein paar
passieren und da wir in der letzten
folge schon überzogen habe die ich schon
mal nicht die vom server aber auf jeden
fall schon mal tschüss an euch ruhig
sagt tschüss bis zum nächsten paar in
dem es in der nächsten folge wieder die
letzte folge damit park und dann
bestätigt auf eine
suche nach einer bis begeben und tschüss